i'm dr tor hanson and today i'll be
answering your questions from twitter
this is more biology support
[Music]
at texas tessa asks hey
biology twitter if a person somehow
found themself in the stomach of a whale
how would they die would they be
digested alive would they drown in
stomach acid would they die from
dehydration well any of those things
would eventually do the person in but
what would probably get them first would
be suffocation because there's not
enough oxygen and there's far too much
carbon dioxide and other gases in the
stomach of that whale for them to
survive at gloomparks asks why do ticks
and fleas and mosquitoes exist like what
do they offer can they die please thanks
well ticks and fleas and mosquitoes may
be annoying to us but they provide a
huge amount of food to all sorts of
creatures in nature the bats and the
birds and the lizards and the turtles
and remember of course even that that
the mosquitoes have a larval phase where
they're living in the water and they're
bountiful food to fishes and other
things so removing those annoyances from
our lives and removing them from the
environment would cause cascading
effects through the food webs and
probably eliminate a lot of other
creatures of which we are much more fond
at slumbuda asks what causes a cell to
die hashtag biology
question well let me count the ways
cells can die from trauma they can die
from disease and certain cells are
programmed to die at certain times in
the lifespan of an organism particularly
during growth and development and
metamorphosis so a tadpole turning into
a frog no longer needs a tail and those
cells die off or a human embryo growing
fingers must kill off the cells in
between the fingers at the right time or
the hand will come out webbed
anna mueller 6 asks why do evergreens
stay green all winter the evergreen
strategy allows those trees to avoid
expending all the energy that's required
in springtime to grow a new set of
leaves they do lose their leaves but
they do it incrementally bit by bit so
that there's always enough foliage on
those trees to photosynthesize whenever
conditions are right at swoosh 61 asks
what is the most recent species to be
confirmed extinct well you include the
word confirmed which is very important
because there are no doubt many species
going extinct right now that we simply
do not have enough data on to say one
way or another but a recent confirmed
extinction is one due to climate change
the first mammal species known to be
lost to the climate crisis the bramble
key maloneys a mouse-like creature whose
entire world really all of its habitat
has now been inundated by rising sea
levels on the islands where it was found
off the coast of australia at db green
alliance asks what is the effect of
climate change on biodiversity how is
the extinction of biodiversity going to
affect homo sapiens as a species there
is an extinction crisis associated with
climate change we are seeing between 25
and 85 percent of the species on the
planet adjusting their ranges in
response to climate change what's the
point of biodiversity in the first place
i like to answer that in three ways by
using different sorts of cartoon
characters the first comes to us from
spider-man where the theme is with great
power comes great responsibility so
because our species has such power over
ecosystems and other species many people
believe we have a responsibility to take
care of them the second example comes to
us from the sorcerer's apprentice where
the mickey mouse character in fantasia
the young apprentice starts reading
spells at random from the spell book and
all hell breaks loose when we
allow biodiversity to go extinct we
don't know what we're messing with and
the third example comes to us from good
old scrooge mcduck donald duck's rich
uncle who might ask about biodiversity
what's in it for me well there's a lot
in it for us as a species we rely upon
biodiversity to pollinate crops to
provide fisheries and forestry products
we rely upon biodiversity to provide
many of our medicinals and when we lose
species without ever having even studied
them we don't know what we're missing at
mo art studio asks humor me what extinct
animal do you wish was still around
today it's very difficult to choose but
i will choose the shasta giant ground
sloth a big shambling beast that once
lived in the mojave desert in the
southwestern part of the united states i
choose it because it was the sole
long-distance seed disperser for another
species that i happen to really love the
joshua tree those giant yucca plants
that exist only in that desert southwest
landscape and that are suffering now
because they can't disperse their seeds
far enough to keep up with the changes
being incurred by global warming so if i
could bring that species back i would
not only get ground sloths but i would
also ensure the future of joshua trees
at elizabergman asks insect armageddon
decline of insects around the world how
are migratory insects going to fare in
light of these environmental changes and
declines well let me answer that
question with another question when was
the last time you had to wipe bug
splatter off of your windshield we've
all experienced that drop off in bug
splatter on our windshields and that
gets at this question of insect
armageddon which is being caused by a
variety of factors from climate change
to pesticides to habitat loss to simply
the way we manage
large portions of land now in our rural
areas where we used to have farms that
were small and varied in crops we are
now very efficient in the way that we
farm we have farmed large areas with
only one crop reducing the quality of
the habitat for a diversity of insects
in fact migratory insects may be at even
greater risk because they encounter
numerous habitats along their journey
and they're particularly vulnerable to
climate change which is altering the
timing of seasonal events so that it's
possible an insect might arrive in a
landscape expecting to feed but be too
early or too late to encounter that
critical source of food
layla asks a quick biology question
please for something i'm writing do
plantae protista monera and fungi
kingdoms need the animalia kingdom at
all i love your question because it
really gets at the interconnectedness of
nature yes we divide all living things
into these five kingdoms the the plants
are the plantae of course things like
amoebas and slime molds in the protists
the monera which describes the bacteria
the fungi which include the familiar
mushrooms and so forth and of course the
animals which is all the rest of us but
if you imagine
how these things are related you start
to see ecology in action imagine the
plants for example without the insects
to pollinate them or try to imagine all
of the bacteria that live even within
our own bodies that rely upon animals
for a habitat if you will and fungi are
turning up everywhere now that we have
the ability to study them through their
dna we can find fungi living inside of
plant leaves and tissues where we never
imagined them before at bayou philosophy
asks sorry for a dumb hashtag biology
question the relationship between
genotype and phenotype is causal right
like the genotype together with the
environment causes a certain phenotype
the answer is yes the genotype the
genetic makeup of the organism causes
the phenotype the physical expression of
that genotype but it's not just like
reading a script and that's because the
genotype responds to cues from the
environment whether it's temperature or
the availability of food or other cues
during the development of that organism
so that it's possible for a genotype to
express quite different phenotypes
depending on the conditions the organism
is living in and one fascinating example
of that comes to us from the gulf of
california in mexico where the humble
squid which once grew in that region to
five or even six feet in length
responded to climate-driven warming of
the water with a different phenotype
same genotype triggering a different
physical manifestation at a much smaller
size the mature squid now rarely exceed
a foot in length at comics mill asks
question for hashtag biology twitter why
do birds know to get out of the way of
oncoming cars but mammals seemingly do
not hashtag deer hashtag headlights well
the answer is birds don't know how to
get out of the way of oncoming cars and
in fact birds make up a considerable
portion of the estimated one million
vertebrate animals that are killed on
roads in north america every single day
including
nocturnal birds like barn owls which fly
low over the roads and often hunt along
the margins of roads and are
particularly vulnerable to being struck
by cars
ido vreeker asks question for biologists
slash biophysicists during a break we
found this mutated daisy outside to me
this seems like a beneficial form of the
daisy larger flower larger chance of
pollination why did a smaller flower and
not this mutation become the standard
form of the flower what you have
discovered is an example of what
botanists would call fasciation which is
a change in the growing tissues of the
plant that cause that sort of a
deformity and it can be triggered by a
an infection it can be triggered by
damage to the tissues
but the reason that it won't be passed
down the reason that you won't see a lot
of daisies looking like that becoming
the dominant form for daisies is that it
is not inherited from one generation to
the next you get the occasional daisy
with that sort of growth form but it's
not passed down at futuresgate asks
what's the oldest tree in existence
what's the oldest tree ever recorded
well the oldest individual trees are
certain bristlecone pines in california
and patagonian cypresses that have been
known to live for 5 000 years but there
are also clonal trees things like
certain aspens or oaks where they are
genetic clones of one another living in
a grove so while individual trunks may
die off the whole organism can live for
tens of thousands of years at eckeresme
asks okay random thought are tomatoes
really fruits then ketchup would be
smoothies right the answer is yes
tomatoes are fruits and we know this
because tomatoes have seeds and fruits
evolved for the sole purpose of luring
animal dispersers like us into moving
fruits away from the parent plant to a
new location where those seeds might
sprout and grow so if you are in the
produce aisle and you see something that
has seeds whether it is a green pepper
or a zucchini or a squash you know that
it must be a fruit so those are all the
questions that we have for today a
wonderful mixture of topics thank you
for watching more biology support